So as we're getting closer and closer to
vaccine approval in the United States,
which could come as soon as Thursday or Friday of
this week or over the weekend, there are more and
more explosive disagreements about what needs
to be done right now in terms of the virus.
And there was a conversation about this that
completely exploded on CNBC a few days ago.
Now, for context, if you've been following the
absolutely horrifying numbers, cases in the
United States have gone off the charts. We've
had as many as 200000 cases per day recently.
And it's not just cases that have been increasing.
Deaths have also exploded. And now looking like we
could have really a sustained period of of 3000
deaths per day for some time, that's essentially
a nine elevens worth of deaths every single day.
Now, assuming the vaccine is shortly approved,
it's going to be a relatively slow rollout.
If you look optimistically, we would have the
capacity to vaccinate maybe six to eight percent
of the population per month, maybe more if we get
a second vaccine, maybe even a third vaccine
approved and starting to be supplied. So the
point is, no matter what, the next three months
are going to be a time where we have to be really,
really careful. So on CNBC anchor Andrew Ross
Sorkin, who has mostly been in favor of just
following what experts say it's not, he's coming
up with the stuff he's mostly been saying. Here's
what the medical experts are saying. He was on an
interview panel with correspondent Rick Santelli.
And Rick Santelli has been wildly out of control,
loudly and defiantly ridiculing and ignoring
varieties of guidelines. And the situation
escalated really quickly. Let's take a look.
Yes. No, believe me, I believe in careful. And
when I point out governors cheating, it's not for
the hypocrisy which exists. It's the fact that
I think many of these governors are intelligent
people and they love their families, which
they've taken out in the restaurants. Therefore,
there is actually and should be an ongoing debate
as to why a parking lot for a big box store like
by my house is Champak, not one parking spot open.
Why are those people any safer than a restaurant
with plexiglass? I just don't get it. And I think
there's a million of these questions that could
be asked. And I think it's really sad that when we
look at the service sector and all the discussions
we've had about job losses, that that particular
dynamic isn't studied more is it worked more. We
don't put more people in a room and try to figure
out ways so that the service sector employees and
employers could all come back and a safer way.
You can't tell me that shutting down, which is the
easiest answer, isn't necessarily the only answer.
So now here so far, although Rick and I could
could do would come to different conclusions, I
don't disagree with Rick about what he's saying.
There are many guidelines, particularly when
you look between states, but also within
states that aren't coherent. He says why
is it safe to jam pack a big box store?
But a small restaurant can't be open, that's a
great question, and in fact, it doesn't appear
to be safe to jam packed the big box store in
many states where people aren't wearing masks,
especially big box stores, are exactly where
a lot of the contagion is happening. Rick is
inadvertently getting to an important point, which
is it's not that open all restaurants. It's the
big box stores aren't actually safe back in early
November. Officials in El Paso, Texas, found a
huge number of cases were being transmitted at big
box stores in El Paso, including Wal-Mart, Target,
Home Depot and Lowe's. So the problem is, Rick,
saying open everything because the big box stores
are open. It seems really what we need is the big
box stores need to dramatically reduce capacity.
So then Andrew Ross Sorkin jumps in
and this gets ugly pretty quickly.
Rick, I just just as a as a public health and
public service announcement for the audience,
the difference between these big box retailers,
is this all about the difference between
the two deals, the difference
between a big box retailer?
Hold on. The difference between a big box
retailer and a restaurant or frankly, even a
church are so different.
It's unbelievable
going into the big box, which is where I disagree.
You're where you can have your thoughts and your
required to where I disagree. Science. I'm sorry.
It's science. We're not such a different story.
500 people in close aren't any safer than one
hundred and fifty people in a restaurant that
holds 600. I don't believe it. Sorry, I don't
believe OK. And I live in an area where there
are a lot of restaurants that have fought back
and they don't have any problems and they're OK.
OK, you don't have to believe it. But let me just
say this. You're doing a disservice to the viewer
because the viewers need to understand
this and a viewer. You are. You are.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry if I would like to keep
our viewers as healthy as humanly possible.
The idea of packing people in a
restaurant, I think our viewers are
smart enough to make the best decisions out there.
So it quickly became know you are, but what am I?
And now Rick actually says something interesting.
Our viewers are smart enough to decide on their
own. That is just not true. I hate it that it's
not true. Check out my video viral video from what
was it a year or so ago. We have to accept that a
lot of people are stupid. Have you seen the Trump
rallies? Were rally goers are asked, why aren't
you wearing a mask? And the answers range from the
virus doesn't exist. It's a fake news. Conspiracy
masks do nothing. I'm protected by Jesus because
I prayed. The problem is you need the guidelines
to be stricter than what most people would need
because there's people that will disregard them
completely. You say outdoors fine without masks,
as was said earlier in the pandemic. Then you see
hundreds of people packing narrow hiking trails
in California. They found the one way to make
outdoor not safe. So now you need to sit well,
you need masks outdoors as well. You got to
close the hiking trails. People aren't smart
enough. That's an unfortunate thing.
Let's see the last bit of this,
different things that I'm much different
than all the viewers like some people do.
Can I get in here, please, and get back to the
doctor for how's that working out for you, Rick?
How's it all working out for you? I mean, look at
the numbers, Rick. It's working out fine. I think
the numbers belie Rick. Rick, the numbers show
that I understand that when people are getting
sick and dying on average, I just think
I know what you're talking about this.
So, of course, the way we've dealt with this
hasn't been optimal. That's absolutely true.
No coordinated federal response going back
ten months now, disinformation coming out of
the White House, the White House, a vector of
disinformation, replacing, you know, we could
pick anything, replacing Dr. Anthony Fauci with
a radiologist for months, as Donald Trump did,
suggesting maybe you inject bleach and hit the
body with disinfectant. But part of the reason
we need to be fighting uphill is because of people
like like Rick Santelli. So I think that listen,
I said before. You look at states with
high and low mask usage, at least on paper,
and sometimes you don't see dramatic differences
in contagion. What explains that? Well,
you've got to dig deeper. Maybe the state with
the high mask usage on paper, people are having
more indoor gatherings because it's a cold
state. And so you don't have people abiding
by only hanging out outdoors. I get that there
are still many questions we don't understand.
You look at Latin American countries
on paper, some of the strictest
guidelines and even actual lockdowns, and they
have some incredible rates of contagion. Well,
when you dig into it, you realize on paper the
guidelines are strict. Nobody's abiding by them.
I get it. But we can't pretend that the problem
is merely that all of the scientists are wrong
and have no idea what's going on. It's absolutely
ridiculous. And that escalated very, very quickly